now for drama political intrigue and
simple craziness manic yeah we gotta
talk about the matches between Karpov
and Korchnoi and there was three of them
and they were three of them now the
first one was an official world champion
for the world championship because it
was the finals of the Candice's who
would play Bobby Fischer
but then Fischer decides not he doesn't
like the terms in 1975 fides not
listening to what he likes and he says
that's it I'm out up until the last day
right and he says I'm out and Karpov is
crowned the world champion because he's
defeated Korchnoi three to two means I
have many draws 25 games Karpov a little
bit of the shoulder right he's thinking
I didn't really beat the guy right so he
has to prove himself and he has to prove
himself himself against it's the same
guy over and over Victoire joy victor
the Terrible keeps coming back again and
again
right so Viktor Korchnoi defects from
the Soviet Union and he becomes the
Challenger officially in 1978 and 1981
and for the whole world championship
cycle of 1980 1981 I was one of the
seconds along with Michael steamed love
Goodman and I got a chance to work with
Viktor for weeks and weeks and months
and months and I'm talking 12 14 hour
days so I get to know the Viktor
Korchnoi and he was a very mixed
personality a man of really strong great
passions this is a guy he would convince
you that he's going to bring that
mountain ten feet closer to his home and
he's gonna do it with the shovel he's
gonna do it every day every day and he
is determined to make that mountain move
well for what I remember is just amazing
his his father I believe died in a
bombing when he was 10 years old again
world war two anymore
or two so Lenny he had he gone in a bomb
in siege of leningrad and he had to go
through all this deprivation to jellify
be who he is to survive survive and he
was known as a guy who if you gave him a
pawn he'd be like thanks for the pawn
I'm walking through the Gobi Desert I'll
do whatever it takes because he was such
a tremendous defender and such a steely
personality really very very much so and
in 1974 that match that he played with
Karpov the finals to determine who was
going to play Bobby Fischer had huge
political overtones in the Soviet Union
because keep in mind there's a Soviet
Chess Federation man but there's the
Russian sports committee in anything
sports goes underneath the Russian
sports company and it was a Russian
sports committee who told the Chess
Federation what's their policy gonna be
and their policy was they wanted to
support the younger Karpov they thought
that that guy had a better chance
against Fischer than did Korchnoi so all
the Soviets were supporting Anatoly
Karpov and Corson told me lots of
stories I can't bore you all with the
stories but they're fine they're fun
so a lot of the grandmasters the soviet
grandmasters could not work with
coronally either officially or in public
or anything and it was all surreptitious
you know you go to the phone booth six
corners away and then you call it eleven
and we'll tell you our analysis kind of
thing I mean it's all cloak-and-dagger
did they have to sign some paperwork
also some of them signed paperwork
against coordinating he decided that he
was gonna defect that was there before
dinner
sorry that's right I remember Karpov
didn't sign I believe Petrossian didn't
sign a couple of others in Simon but but
they had to say that's right
this guy persona non grata to us that's
right because he decided he had to he
left behind his wife and yeah Bella yeah
Bella and Igor so okay so the point is
it goes efore 6 d 4 D 5 it's a French
now Korchnoi is playing the French too
fence against Anatoly Karpov and Karpov
playing the tirage was 92 so Roman gingy
Haj really who couldn't be his official
second right has been working on the
move Bishop f8 to e7 on move three it's
a special special move right and then
Victor gets into a telephone
conversation with David Bronstein okay
top guy and he's on the phone and he and
David says I've got a move for you on
move three a bishop move for you to play
against Karpov and I've worked it all
out and he goes yeah yeah I know it's
Bishop e7 and gingi told me
no it's Bishop d7 Bishop c8 to d7 on
move three against the terrace and you
can go into the Fort Knox variation so
it's hilarious that there's gorgeous nor
juggling two top grandmasters that he
can't meet then with them in public
because of the Soviet Union and then the
match continues with this kind of
intrigue throughout throughout the snap
they happen in this manner yogurt game
because that comes later yeah in the
ladder matches right where you get will
you get these you can't bring the yogurt
to the table because there might be a
code depending on which color yogurt was
correct and a parapsychologist that's
right where the they're using their
minds to influence the way you're
thinking right and guys can't sit in the
front of row because you guys are
psychologists who are intimidating them
with with their minds I mean I was a
wild stuff exactly but even before we
get into the 78 match though we got the
75 match to deal with so so there's
Fischer list of demands gonna play this
young punk kid Anatoly Karpov Ferdinand
Marcos says let's cut the crap
here's five million dollars now keep in
mind that Bobby Fischer played Boris
Spassky how much chordoma correct
five million dollars I don't want to
hear about some rules and what's gonna
happen and then the five million dollars
get your butt over here to play I think
even Carlson and Caruana would play for
fighting today's dollars much less those
dollars seventy five so it's amazing to
chess fans myself especially included
when I say that how Bobby turned that
down that was just for the straight
twenty four game which became the
standard after world war two you played
twenty four games he Bobby wanted to
play like Stein it's the first two ten
victories wins the match
caught by nine keeping the title for the
champ that's right he disagreed suit
that's right so they went to the first
to win six they changed the rules as a
compromise Bobby said I ain't playing
Muhammad Ali and George Foreman they're
thriller and Manila Bobby Fischer didn't
come and pick up the paycheck Muhammad
Ali and George Frazier did that was what
that money came from
George no George Frazier Frazier Ali go
Frazier Joe Frazier sorry
yeah Joe Frazier that was where that
money came from was from the chess match
1978 Manila was wild that's where you
get your parapsychologist that's where
you this is Baguio City all right Bobby
oh yeah
that's where Anatoly Karpov man you know
like some servant would come and bring
them a tea or a coffee there enough
here's the tea or coffee but on our
number one he get a yogurt but what kind
of a yogurt if it's a blueberry yogurt
maybe that's a thing you should be
moving your knife if it's raspberry you
know what raspberry sounds like Bishop
berries bishop raspberries etc it was
some wild stuff yeah went on you know we
really should give karpova's do I know
you were playing on Korchnoi Steam are
you were 1981 fortunately but Karpov
does win both matches there are
incredible
fights that just struggles beyond belief
epic stuff
that is people should really be looking
at but Karpov does win both and he goes
on to prove him silver the next 10 years
that he's really the true champion
that's because he's got the chip on his
shoulder that Bobby Fischer never
knocked off because he won the match by
forfeit and every game he plays he comes
with the attitude I've got to prove
myself gotta prove that I'm the real
world champion and in those 10 years he
was phenomenon he was a dominant world
champion go look at that go look at that
tournament record until we meet one
youngster that is to come but certainly
epic those two double K matches one of
many that will happen between Karpov and
Korchnoi
yes certainly a storybook time in chess
World Championship history absolutely
you